et affoussy bamba l'avocate de guillaume
soro bonjour affoussy bamba merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux
propos d'abdoulaye meïté l'avocat de
l'état de la côte d'ivoire on vient
d'entendre un instant avant de réagir
la fep propos de me donner quand même
juste quelques vous me donnez la
priorité de donner quelques mots sur le
jugement qui a été en juillet alors ces
jugements pour nous est un jugement
nulle et de nul effet
un jugement qui n'aurait jamais dû être
obtenue à l'apa par le fait qu' il y
avait il y avait une décision qui a été
rendue par la cour africaine des droits
de l'homme et cette décision les
implacables est très claire elle dit
trois choses en substance elle vit
premièrement il faut un sursis à
l'exécution du mandat d'arrêt contre
monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro un
sursis d'un mandat de dépôt décerné à
l'endroit de tous ses proches dont de
tous ceux qui ont été interpellés
sauvagement et emprisonnés le 23
décembre 2019
elle dit qu'il peut le faire dans un
délai de 30 jours
mais ce qu'elle dit ce qui est
extraordinaire qu'est le quatrième point
parce que je n'avais pas évoqué elle dit
qu'il faut observer un statu quo en b un
statu quo en tête par rapport à qui la
procédure concernant qu'ils seront donc
ça veut dire que tout quelques ensuite
les instructions dans le dossier de
aurait dû s'arrêter
on aurait dû tout arrêter nous aurions
dû revenir comme si rien ne s'était
produit c'est-à-dire avant le 23
décembre 2019
dans cette optique là vous comprenez que
la des audiences d'hier et le juge
mental a résulté n'aurait pas dû être
rendu
donc c'est important de le préciser et
moralement pour répondre à plus
prosaïquement à la question qui a été
évoqué par le conseil d'état de côte
d'ivoire de monsieur ouattara
je le dirai que c'est quand même du
temps qui se moque de la charité
voilà un président qui est arrivé aux
affaires qui a critiqué ses
prédécesseurs s'y colla
je veux parler du président henri konan
bédié avait un poids de soins c'est le 5
milliards pour l'autre je veux parler du
président laurent gbagbo avait un point
de s'arrêter de 18 milliards il me
semble et je ne me trompe pas et lui
aujourd'hui qui a trois enfants de
droite 30 milliards de forêt
souveraineté lui parler de corruption
lui alassane ouattara peut parler de
corruption
lui dont la gouvernance depuis qu'il a
pris le pouvoir
depuis 2010 2011 exactement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui est émaillée de scandales en
corruption
justement facilement nos vingt films de
fiction soyons quand même sérieux vous
parlez de ville à vous de donner non on
ne peut pas dire que lui là vous nous
donner justement un des clips que la
venue donner un taux de départ à la fin
du gouvernement mais qu'il commande par
tous les ministres qui sont confirmées
par des dossiers de corruption
là on dirait qu effectivement est
atteint d'un problème sérieux qu'il
commence par là soyons sérieux
vous avez évoqué guillaume soro alassane
ouattara laurent gbagbo
on sait qu'il ya là la présidence un la
course à la présidence en octobre
prochain votre client dénonce donc une
condamnation politique est ce que tout
cela est lié à l'élection présidentielle
de cet automne naturellement vous le
comprenez bien le pouvoir d'abidjan
vient de nous démontrer qu'ils ont peur
d'une seule personne
monsieur guillaume kigbafori soro c'est
très clair parce que fils ne l'était pas
on ne comprendrait pas autrement tout ce
qu'il faut voilà des personnes qui
décident
l'émission d'un mandat et qu'elle vient
l'heure de jeu sur guillaume soro défi
de rentrer en côte d'ivoire non non non
il voudrait que le paravent pour
qu'elles n'ont pas qu'avant ils pètent
et de raviver le défi de l'émission des
mandats on est un parc tout proche qui
était l un comme on appelle ça qui était
au siège du parc du mouvement gp 1 qui
était en pleine conférence de presse
on les interpelle et on les interpelle
sur quelle balle pour quel motif d'un
motif tout aussi fallacieux effet faire
sommes sont en prison aujourd'hui
depuis depuis décembre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est sérieux ça
ça montre que le combat a peur le
pouvoir a peur de ces mondiaux
s'il ne parle pas de ceux qui n'auraient
pas sorti toutes ces chefs d'accusation
contre lui 6 mars il avait pâti parle de
lui il aurait dû se conformer à la
décision de la cour africaine des droits
de l'homme
merci le l'état de côte d'ivoire est
partie prenante de l'union africaine
l'état de côte-d'ivoire à un succès une
déclaration pour dire qu'elle reconnaît
la compétence de l'union africaine et
qu'elle elle elle est d'accord pour
appliquer les testeurs de l'union
africaine
donc à partir de ce moment là on ne
comprend pas qu'il se passe on ne
comprend pas pourquoi il ya eu audiences
après la réunion qui a rendu la cour
africaine des droits de l'homme
merci à fossier bamba d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'avocate de guillaume soro